you believe in god of course okay so I
believe in God as well okay so we we all
need Grace no I know I need Grace
I know I need Grace
you ever need Grace
yeah God is Grace okay so if if I know
um I need God and I know I don't know it
all
it would help for me to have wise
counsel right because they say you know
who gonna counsel me I got more than the
council well there's plenty of other
people that have more than you and me
that can give us counsel I have a board
that counsels me they have more than I
do and I do pretty well I need a counsel
about better opportunities
Venom circumstances
but but do you know what I'm asking you
do you know what you asked yeah what I'm
asking is I don't know it all
so the fact that I don't know it all the
fact that I don't know it I don't know
what we got to know I do know it as
Google is detailed references whatever I
need to know I can know yeah but
sometime when you're making a decision
like like a decision like what what
decisions you just help me out you just
help me with a decision yeah you just
helped me with a big decision you don't
even know it good say what it is it's my
nine-year-old how to handle them I just
got counsel from you because I'm not in
the world you just give me incredible
feedback that when I go to my wife
tonight I want to tell them let me tell
you what this guy said and I'm going to
bring that up to my wife and I'm gonna
say let me tell you what he said he said
if he said but I wasn't Council that was
just a positive idea but I pre I receive
it as counsel I receive it as counsel
because not counseling because I'm
having a conversation with you I'm
giving a new idea I'm not counseling you
but what I'm doing is I'm receiving it
counselors when you get in trouble they
take you to the council office so you
could they could tell you like hey if
you whatever we could do to get you can
change the word for advice I'm on the
right page I'm from Liberty City I'm the
light I became uh you know I did a great
career in the NFL and I walked off and
made another one so you don't think you
can learn from anybody everyone can
always learn bro but I don't need
counseling bro you need counseling
because you don't understand
yeah I I I'm not at your level of
intelligence that's for sure I need help
I'm not a sentence I need advice I need
counseling intelligent well I mean I'm
not saying you at my level let me frame
it
a different way just privilege who was
your favorite coach ever played under
code man the last one
who's that brazarians no not that guy
that guy
who's your last coach Belichick
no he's talking Tomlin
probably my tea my my favorite Mike
Tomlin was your favorite coach you've
ever played for yeah and what about him
made him your favorite coach
you know how to get the best out of
players okay so as an example that's
someone that you would see Council he
was your coach and the Council of a man
he's a coach football coach that's not a
counselor but that's in that's now
counseling they paid me for skills to
play ball I don't need counseling okay I
need a coach to make sure the team
online but I got I'm the player with the
skills to do the job fair point he was
paying me man if you guys don't
understand me you guys okay all right so
under me so if it has to do with pay
then let me flip it on you then you've
hired lawyers you've hired doctors
you've hired estate planners I assume
you've hired CPAs there's people you
surround yourself with they're not
canceled abroad as employees w9s that do
a service a job okay exactly but they
you give them they give you counsel God
is a Melody counselor with my family and
my peoples no one give me counsel you
know what I'm saying well maybe I'm
self-sufficient here maybe the first
rule of law is self-sufficient
self-preservation the first realize that
preservation I'm self-sufficient
that's how you can make it from Liberty
City can you look up the percentage of
guys who make it from Liberty City not a
lot exactly so I wanted a few chosen so
I should be giving counsel that's why
I'm here I'm giving counsel facts but
also you could receive counsel is what
he says always it's receptive okay
giving them receiving the information is
receptive man so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]